this is Rafael he's been diagnosed with
OCD here is one example I did open up no
you did it it's open no it's not this
was open look look it's open there's
this chocolate pudding right there well
open you mean this right here no right
here right here yeah you want me to take
this off this off this yeah are you
gonna be able to eat it if I don't take
it off you did take it off again it's
completely open raffia you can eat it
not yes yes yes no you can eat it right
now not yet no no good uh-oh
oh don't pick it out you're not gonna
take it out it's open if it wasn't open
I wouldn't be in the trouble of honey
look no you don't do that is a droplet
pudding get your spoon and put it in
there I got I got it yeah
okay now eat it no yeah after I open
honey
it's it's open there's nothing there
look look look on the other side look
underneath of it say there's nothing
here it's a lip you could cut it off and
it wouldn't matter because your
chocolate pudding is in the middle of
see ya later
well you're violating my finger there
okay go ahead and eat your chocolate
city you don't
I think you'll be just fine don't you do
you think you'll be just fine yeah all
right take a bite I want to make sure
it's open all the way take a bite no it
really won't happen because we're trying
not yet we're not we're not trying to do
that okay we're not trying to do that
we're just we opened the pudding
we opened it it's open you can put your
spoon in it and you can put it in your
mouth
yeah and that little piece of paper is
not going to control your whole life no
it's not yes it's really not it's
insignificant
dad chill don't think about it you know
just eat your chocolate pity don't think
about that piece of paper nobody cares
about that piece of paper money yeah we
just care about the chocolate pudding
right you know Carol that chocolate
pudding we care about the chocolate
pudding no we don't we don't care about
that paper that paper has nothing to do
with us it's just being there and wants
to be left alone so leave it alone and
eat your chocolate pudding is it good
yeah I love it yeah yeah
pleases gravely Channel and check out
the channel we may give videos every day
thank you for watching have a great day